so how how did it all start for you then  jean marco if you  you're saying that you were a theater  kid i mean out in new york yeah i went  to college from musical theater  and then i  then they kind of beat the joy out of i  don't think i was a singer i don't i  really i've only been booked to sing  these days at my grandparents funerals  so it's it's that's only full of times  yeah yeah yeah it's a it's a bummer  it's it's i'm a good reminder there's  things worse limited run  um  it's uh  so i loved i used to love musical  theater and then i moved to philly i was  in like a meisner-based acting company  brilliant cult  um it really had the whole whenever i  see a cult documentary i see the whole  trajectory of this acting company  from you know worship of the leader  leader starts to have flaws crumbles  half the company loves her half the  company's rebelling  chaos with me and hold me tight all  through the night you're shining bright  i'm your host the baby you're my  [Music]